logo reading the year was 1891 narrow
typing also character in a movie is
writing a literal book about the events
of the movie cliche straight-up theft
I've been following you for the last
half mile motives I can say they're not
pursuing me there's according me and
they seem to be doing a terrible job
since they allow Sherlock to take your
package and talk to you alone this whole
time
also Sherlock Holmes best detective in
the world knew he needed to be in the
market place dressed in a costume to
uncover a dastardly plot today but
couldn't figure out that the men
following Irene were actually with her
19th century beat down music let's go
thrust
you know Robert Downey jr. Sherlock
Holmes is basically Johnny Depp's Jack
Sparrow
we're not the without the yeah I know
they're basically the same character I
can't believe I never noticed that
before now yep Sherlock Holmes are still
Larry Holmes look you want to show the
power of Holmes mind by allowing him to
be slightly more predictive in a fist
fight than his opponent fine I think
it's stupid but fun but you can't show
him literally predicting this asshole
will pull a gun on it especially since
he works for Rachel McAdams and she
clearly didn't want home skill there's a
difference between predictive cognition
during fighting and flat-out Nostradamus
the director said let's have him catch
an apple that stayed in the air an
impossibly long time during the fight so
he'll look like even more of a Madonna
I mean asshole I said asshole look I
know he's the best detective ever and
all but how did he know Irene would be
delivering this package to this dude at
an auction house and how did he get here
in time after fighting those four
bodyguards 1 million pounds
Sherlock set this pipe up to set a fire
in the auction house but it's this how
pipes work you just set it next to a
flammable object and whatever it's near
goes up in flames with perfect timing
Ramsey's ex machina so did anyone put
out that fire or was the fire's
existence directly proportional to our
concern with it won't Sherlock Holmes
started dealing with the bump wait
are all these people hypnotized are they
all in the sunken place because they
sure as hell knew to get out once that
teacup was struck
huh it's that guy from Mad Men and why
does the movie spend so much of the
first nine minutes building up this
mastermind criminal no one has ever seen
just to blow the reveal wad at the
nine-minute 42nd mark I like how he's so
smart and omnipotent as to be in
disguise pretending to be asleep on the
street earlier when Adler walks by with
a dangerous package but then stupid
enough not to think she might be in
danger after he stopped the package bomb
from going off and just going to the
restaurant like a stupid puppy dog they
said eight o'clock he waited an hour in
ten minutes before getting concerned
wait he's not even concerned ma'am this
guy I'm going to overlook the sudden
green house inside Holmes's home and go
straight for this turkey species native
to North America which means somehow in
the early 1890s Sherlock Holmes he of
the social anxiety and reclusiveness has
either travelled to America to purchase
or steal a turkey or has been sent one
as a gift by an American possibly Edison
and both of these explanations failed to
excuse this turkey the turkey is being
sent deal with it he's been on a diet of
coffee tobacco and coca leaves throw in
a little cocaine and you got the Mickey
work meal plan while I applauded the
film's attempt to show us Holmes
obsession with this case there are
definitely more red lines on this board
than there are things a red line might
connect another thing to follow that
strand that strand that one strand this
newspaper clipping about an Indian
cotton tycoon has a column on the left
and a column on the right that are the
exact same paragraphs it's a game dear
man a shadowy game that's good enough
for me we're all credits sir do you mind
terribly if I try mine gene extract
experimenting on animals
I expect the clip to come down on you
heart why are you looking at me with
such concern I'm so very worried your
vitality speed range from you will be
has time for this
where's the thing about Switzerland no
the worst thing about Switzerland is
definitely their over-reliance on
novelty multi-purpose knives girls
swinging upside-down in 90s on a circus
swing over what appears to be a
shuffleboard table and honestly I'm
curious how the screenwriter was able to
access my very specific teenage dreams
you can
she forgot about my stag party didn't
you even though Watson knows Holmes
better than anybody he actually thought
for even the briefest moment that Holmes
planned out his stag party
this despite seeing his Moriarty wall
which pretty much should have told him
right then and there that Holmes didn't
plan a party well that he's a selfish
asshole
there's a man conceived in the rafters
above us so it's safe to presume that
your next client is here to kill you the
real question is why didn't he already
he had the chance to kill her before
Sherlock even walked in maybe the reason
he's been stuck up there is so we can
yet again be delivered proof how amazing
Sherlock is at Holmes a first pillaged
the nest Jesus I am so over Sherlock
Holmes megha 13 abilities Sherlock who
once again predicted everything this
assassin was gonna do somehow didn't
predict this what a dumbass well this is
an impressive set of acrobatics I'm
wondering how the newer homes would be
at this very moment unnecessary
matrixing also this guy does a backflip
against the wall and his back has still
turned away from Holmes after flipping
so what was the point of that you don't
get style points in a fight he lives
because he landed on that green pillow
in 1891 London if you found yourself
fighting in the street at night there
was always the constant danger of a gang
of gamblers kidnapping you and forcing
you to box to their pleasure just a
constant threat an epidemic really
killed more people than the play movie
seems to be ringing laughs from how
clueless Watson is to Holmes current
predicament like he should be helping
the home specifically didn't tell Lots
and why they were here so him laughing
shouldn't be funny it should be what we
expect him to be doing
[Music]
now wait a minute is that the rule if
the gambling table is knocked over by a
fight the money already in the pot for
the current hand is open to grams to
anyone nearby this seems like the very
definition of bad form
Sherlock has a kick so powerful that it
knocks a nimble assassin through some
doors and well into the water below I'm
going to make a bet that Sherlock has
never successfully kicked a man in the
air thirty feet away on the fly before
tonight but I agree the scene needed to
be over and I'm glad it is it's the 19th
century so cars aren't going nearly fast
enough for this deer to appear suddenly
and crash into the carriage like a
horror film but I'd remove 100 sins if
it did Jesus
Watson's stag party and his wedding were
so close together that there was
absolutely no way he was gonna show up
to his wedding sober no lie I saw this
chalkboard and immediately thought
Rambaldi Holmes has to be smart enough
to guess that any evidence see spots in
this office is potentially staged right
right the strain proves too much fire
it's only a matter of time before a
chessboard shows up damn it
with tragic consequences this seems to
be the actual first moment he has even
thought about Adler since his lunch with
her my respect for you mr. Holmes is the
only reason you're still alive the fact
that the assassin you sent during that
whole casino parkour parry failed
another time then just-just-just well I
am definitely going to write a potential
audio outtake here with the Harry Potter
music but I also want to point out how
obvious it is this nighttime train scene
was shot during the day and artificially
nighttime Jesus Christ these assassins
sure love their knives don't they ever
thought of using the element of surprise
or maybe use a gun sometime
looks like Sherlock will have a lot of
explaining to do once Hercule Poirot
starts asking questions about who got
murdered on this Oregon Express throw
Mary from the train sink nobs somehow
opens this very important compartment on
the train got it so Holmes replaced two
shells with lipstick and this somehow
managed to save the day I mean with most
of Holmes schemes you think yeah that's
kind of far-fetched but sure with this
it requires so much luck you might as
well call them Sherlock Holmes
liddie goes full david fincher here and
look even david fincher learned to tone
this down after a few movies whereas
this is one of Guy Ritchie's later films
in his career I'm not sure why the bad
guys even thought they'd need a machine
gun when they were sent to kill Watson
but why didn't they just use that in the
first place I had a whole box of
grenades too I mean remember how they
first tried to kill wonsan it was a dude
with a knife since then they've gone all
out with shotguns machine guns and
grenades
this isn't that difficult you
the most sensible honeymoon destination
of all is this training really still
going is the conductor asleep or is this
on some sort of autopilot
you know how I know this music is Hans
Zimmer because I'm pretty sure this
music was in Pirates of the Caribbean
before follow mine huh that's weird
that's exactly what I call my boner just
so that I guess so that Holmes can I
told you so wats it again and no other
reason to very smart people will now get
highwayman by discount artful dodger
here in his crew why so a wives salon
located near his printing press um not
necessarily but you're right so that's
ridiculously amazing I mean it's not
like they couldn't just have a bottle of
wine somewhere other than a wine cellar
or the million other ways wine could
just happen to be on a paper you
understand how a man particular
disposition under the certain
circumstances might grow to enjoy the
company of a person of your gender first
off is this the movies weird way of
telling us Mycroft is gay second off is
this the movies weird way of telling us
Mycroft doesn't comprehend life
infiltrating a huge commercial kitchen
is super easy because everyone is
overworked underpaid and could give a
rat's ass 17 HT not a seminal vintage oh
sommeliers are amazing because they can
discern wines and vintages by smell and
taste at class level Holmes is far
enough away he might not even smell this
dude's farts given the wind currents at
the time from this Sherlock figures out
that there must be a secret room behind
this wall this is the power of
Sherlock's keen sense of observation and
apparently reading the screenplay plus
like there's 2 X ma catism one here so
that's what we call a duo ex machina to
the off breath this is a battle cry that
would only rally Fraser his brother
Niles probably max from Rushmore Patrick
Bateman and date and Thomas Nikki Ripley
Greenleaf Sherlock now realizes that
he's been set up but just peace proves
it but think of all the things that had
to go right for this to go wrong
Sherlock would have had to figure out
that sims's letter was printed in a
place with a printing press next to a
wine cellar would have to go to an
anarchist groups headquarters talk to
the leader had the leader kill himself
then figure out there was a secret room
where he worked on a prop for the Don
Giovanni opera Oh while ignoring the
other clues that he is just now
remembered pretty damn convenient how
closely this opera mirrors this cutaway
scene of gun war aftermath and has
needed a wind gauge she placed here and
I'll prove that by pointing to this
random spot on the ledge that has no
evidence at all seriously out of all the
things they figure out from this rooftop
that the assassin used a wind gauge and
where he placed it provides zero
information that is used
a way to conceal a killing no one looks
for a bullet hole in a bomb blast or
stick with me now
you don't even shoot him at all and you
let the bomb do the killing am I missing
something here
last night's bombing was clearly meant
to look like Germany's retaliation for
Strasburg why would the Russians hold a
grudge against the Washington Nationals
but taking 10 minutes to get to the
shell bandit will agree where the
largest concentration of the winged
vermin may be found reduces their to 1
the garden or Holmes assumes that
Moriarty would need to find the largest
concentration of pigeons in order to
indulge his little habit it makes
several stops along the way one of which
is a brawn where my nods factory is
couldn't you figure this out without
knowing Moriarty likes to feed the
pigeons you know he just killed mine
heart and you know mine horn has a
weapons Factory in Germany also if
Sherlock was so amazing with his
disguises why didn't he just follow
Moriarty instead of working all his
brain power on a problem that seems
pretty easy unfortunately due to the
bombing crossing between France and
Germany is to be closed
apparently despite this fact it closes
after Moriarty crosses the border right
that's pretty convenient for him
inconvenient for our heroes oh well the
girl with the dragon tattoo has to be
good for something no one will be seated
during the True Grit portion of the
movie and then Sherlock lord of the
rings' himself to his next destination
here we go with Sherlock Holmes
telescopic eyesight he went to an
optometrist and they found out his
vision is 20 negative 30 Holmes is
pretty stupid for a guy that's such a
genius come at once if convenient if
inconvenient come all the same it's
amazing how they put the exact words I
used to say to my ex-girlfriend in
college right into this movie complete
with the picture of the watchtower
I mean what
charming lark about it crime solver goes
full 0.34 a bit and hopes you don't lose
your sense of humor it was nice of
Moriarty to bring along his record
player in a Schubert album with him on
this trip to Germany torture music is so
much better when it's classical Watson's
head is in the light right and Sebastian
just shot his cap when he held it up to
the light right why isn't he shooting
now to whom did you send
I thought Moriarty new homes in such a
way that he was nearly as equal wouldn't
he know that he sent the telegram to
Mycroft
there's almost nobody else Sherlock
could have sent it to and this is why
he's keeping Sherlock a lot that's not
fair and thus the phrase all's fair in
love and war was born everyone who
should be dead from this won't be do you
know what's missing from almost every
film adaptation of Sherlock Holmes
gunplay machineguns and shootouts only
30 minutes left on the movie suddenly
gets a terrible case of Zack Snyder its
this Band of Brothers ripoff isn't cool
and it's not made any cooler by the
regular speed then slow then fast than
regular editing style either Oh No Marco
his sin was being too unimportant to
this story movie wastes an inordinate
amount of time trying to make us believe
Sherlock Holmes is dead in his own movie
with 30 minutes left
this whole brother pulp fiction is
unacceptable movie that has stolen half
of it from other movies continues the
tradition by stealing this impossible
mountainside log from Batman Begins also
how would such a massive waterfall work
at snow-capped mountain level altitudes
answer it wouldn't if we can find him
and stop him we were perhaps not only
save his life but prevent the collapse
of Western civilization Iron Man is just
gonna bleed a bit into every role Robert
Downey jr. plays from this point forward
I guess those twins weren't twins my
suspicions were aroused at high ball
when one failed to go - wait a minute
there were twins in this movie I don't
like all this movie making a big deal
about them even when they introduced
them here I didn't even know that we're
supposed to be twins there are so many
white dudes with beards in this movie
all of them look alike a five-minute
game think you can manage it an
ambassador is about to get murdered but
Sherlock and Moriarty decide to conduct
a dick-measuring contest playing chess
by the way if Sherlock loses this match
does that mean anything does Watson have
to stop looking for the assassin if
Moriarty checkmate Sherlock and after so
consumed with his performance that the
one character
Tukey cannot accommodate a spontaneous
reaction this doesn't prove if this is
what proves who the assassin is then I'm
an assassin because I never react the
dishes being dropped when I'm at a
restaurant sure I guess with a war
looming maybe everyone innocent reacts
to spilled dishes doesn't prove anything
I can this guy killed the ambassador it
would have been easy enough to frame the
people you wanted to frame without going
through the trouble of putting a guy
through identical twin surgery is being
assassin guy lingers just long enough
and just right and Watson spotting him
and assuming a whole bunch of that guy
could have left discreetly or by a dozen
other exits hell he could have gone into
the party instead of leaving this is
just some contrive to create a chase
scene I attended several of your
lectures Sherlock went to Moriarty's
lectures apparently with the idea in
mind to draw attention to himself and to
a man obsessed with him this disguise is
so bad it's good I guess
but the notebook would undoubtedly be
encoded so happened to break the code
that's easy
the key is Tesla never mind it's safe in
London but my colleagues are making good
use of it if the little notebook that
Moriarty carried around contain the
location of a fortune that the police
discovered was a crime then why couldn't
this have been used to keep Moriarty out
of the Peace Conference
otherwise its money they can't trace and
can't prove anything with and can't
legally seize it Bishop to Bishop 8
discover Jack and incidentally mate I
would have removed a hundred sins if
that wasn't checkmate and Maury already
ended up winning the chess match but
Holmes still won the other more
important chess match Moriarty has
always been portrayed as Holmes
intellectual equal so for this movie of
course things come down to a fist fight
yeah so not a good idea to kill off one
of Sherlock's most popular villains I
mean yeah they could always have brought
him back to life if they wanted to
continue the series but then that would
cheapen the sacrifice Sherlock makes
here of course he's not that either so
it's already kind of cheap he died at 37
haha wow the movie made some brief
mention of this breathing device 20
minutes ago am I really expected to know
what the fuck it is now my thing was so
unimportant it's kind of amazing even
Watson remembers anything about it
apparently so you're pretty much owned
by Disney to do Ironman for the rest of
your life
so no more homes despite this being a
big hit good feelings gone your hedge
needs trimming wasn't expecting a rain
forest you could fall in love with an
orangutan in
because you're much I walk the line is
even a good use of my old office fuck
man you see hey so they can do what a
present on kiddo really what let's go
[Music]
you shouldn't hang me on a hook my
father hung me on a hook once once that
was trippy
[Applause]
[Music]